so let me explain to you guys um a
little bit about how i started my events
and what i would what i would do if i
was starting again which is basically if
i was starting again i would do mostly
the same stuff but i think everyone in
the next if you're listening if you're
willing to spend eight weeks working 40
hours a week dedicated to this i think
you could make at least 100 000 profit
starting probably in
september because that's when uh i think
events conferences are going to be okay
so anyway um the the biggest thing that
you have to do here is your email list
is the most important thing so the
hustlecon.com i launched that website on
june 6th okay and within just a few
weeks we were averaging around a
thousand or 2000 unique visitors a day
and the email list jumped from about 200
people to about 2 500 people in seven
weeks
keep in mind at the time i didn't even
have a twitter so there was no twitter i
mean there was but i didn't use it and
so what i would do is hustlecon.com was
basically a landing page where it
explained what the event is and then
you'd enter your email and that was
called the front door the side doors
were all these blog posts so i would
write two to three blog posts a week on
each speaker i would post that on hacker
news people would come to the website
via the side door
only
five percent of them would say this is
interesting what's this website and they
would click the home page and i would
collect their email there and then once
i collected their email i would send
them a variety of other blog posts that
i'd written and at the end of each blog
post that i sent them it would say ps
this person is speaking at hustlecon on
uh august 1st in september you can get a
ticket right now for 10 off if you buy
the next 12 hours right by the way the
next 12 hours that code was working all
the time
it was always the next 12 hours the
countdown clock there's a simple plug-in
that you could buy and it just starts
and shows up so sorry guys i'm sure
everyone knows this now but
i don't even shopify wasn't popular at
that point so
um not everyone had that technology but
that's what we did pretty easy pretty
basic and in doing that i'll give an
example of the blog post because i
remember like i remember vividly the one
you did about i cracked
um which you kind of did like as
infographic i remember the one of
pandora so i would do but explain what
yeah
explain what you did and like also these
were speakers so you got speakers to
agree legit speakers to agree before you
even had an audience or anything
yes which is the second thing i'm going
to talk about is how to land a speaker
but the the blog post i basically would
just use forbes business insider all
these places and just write a biography
on the person but i would do it in an
interesting way and eventually what
happened is we would create infographics
so um i had john who worked there and i
would say um john um here's the here's
the bulleted points of their life turn
it into an infographic please and that's
what we did we had infographics it could
have been a blog post which is what i
used to do we this time we made
infographics and it worked quite well
and it was basically
i read the book made to stick and i just
copied that so i took uh information
about their company and i made it really
easy to understand so for example
pandora streams
this amount of music per hour which is
the equivalent of x y and z uh they the
reason why they were able to do that is
they were one of the first people to
launch on the iphone um and then i like
i just tell that story
pretty simple i thought it was simple
very effective now that's how we got our
initial sales now the thing about sales
for events it's incredibly stressful the
reason it's stressful is typically
20 of your sales come in the first five
to seven days and then 20 sometimes more
30 of your sales comes in the last like
four or five days which means that dead
time so you you won't you have to get
you got to kick ass right out of the
right out of the gate so your first
launch series you need to kick ass your
first email launch series you need to do
really well then there's a fair bit of
dead time and it feels we're failing
we're failing we're failing and then the
last 10 days or so you get a wave of
sales and it all comes down to the last
minute and it is incredibly
nerve-wracking and anything can ruin it
for example a pandemic or if there was a
terrorist attack if there was um
um um
bad weather as simple as bad weather
you're and so you've been working
for seven weeks and now eventually in
our case a whole year on this event and
you're screwed so it's very stressful
but the way that you can actually make
more money and this is a something that
i didn't learn until later on for the
tickets you actually want to charge
higher than you than you can so let's
say you want to make a hundred thousand
dollars and you want to get a thousand
people to pay you 100 you always charge
250 and then you give more you give
discounts in order to get to 100 average
sale price and so you want in my opinion
you want to be very generous with
discounts but you want to charge a lot
of money so it anchors it at a high at a
high value yeah
correct and one other thing that you
want to do is you want to run this like
an ecom site so for an ecomp site you
say well i want to make 100 grand this
month therefore i need to get um
um you know a hundred thousand people to
my uh a hundred thousand high quality
people on my website of which three
percent are going to convert i know
three percent are going to convert
because i'm constantly tinkering with my
landing page the average sale value is
going to be x dollars therefore this is
how you do it now i just need to get
people to my website
that's what a lot of conference people
don't do that's what you should do
and it works quite well
um and then finally time is one of the
best ways to create sales so
you have to give discounts early on
and at the end and you and the goal is
you want to have five three to five
tiers of pricing so you want to have
early early bird and then early bird and
then middle bird and then
you're late okay seriously this is the
last reminder late like you because if
you actually look so can you actually
see um if you log into that doc i
actually put a chart of my very first
event uh from july of 24. you're gonna
see big spikes
every single one of those big spikes was
a new ticket tier ending and there's a
direct correlation between the amount of
revenue that i made that day and the
amount of like the tier ending and um
me sending an email blast reminding
people and i would email some two or
three times a day in order to remind
them wow
[Music]
you